สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครู
หญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะครียมวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
ค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
2 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคมค่ะปีพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 ค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศอะไรคะ
ค.ศ
2022 ค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครู
เรียมตอนนี้ 9:30 นอืม 930 นครูเหรียมกิน
ข้าวหรือยังคะยังไม่กินข้าวเลยค่ะครูกง
อุ๊ยหิวมั้ยหิวค่ะหิวค่ะแบบท้องไส้ปั่น
ปวดเออใช่คุณหญิงกังจะถามเลยว่าปกติเนี่ย
ถ้าเป็นช่วง 900 นครูเรียมเนี่ยกินข้าวมย
ทุกๆวันถ้าอทุกวันเนี่ยกินข้าวแล้วใช่
มั้ยคะ 99:00 นเนี่ยกินข้าวแล้วออแล้ววัน
นี้เนี่ย 9:30 นยังไม่ได้กินข้าวท้องน่า
จะไม่โอเคนะน่าจะแบบปั่นป่วนเหมือนครู
เรียมบอกปั่นป่วนใช่เพราะว่าวันนี้เรียม
แบบเพิ่งตื่นมาตอน 8 นครึ่งแล้วเรียมก็
แบบนัดกับครูหญิงไว้ 9:00 นก็เลยแบบมาๆๆ
อาบน้ำหวีผมหวีผมแต่งหน้าแต่งหน้าแต่ง
หน้าธรรมดาคือตื่นขึ้นมาแล้วก็จะหิวเลย
ต้องกินข้าวอ๋อวันนี้ตื่นขึ้นมาก็มาทำงาน
ก่อนค่ะก็เลยแบบท้องยังแบบอาจจะปั่นป่วน
นิดหน่อยเนาะเพราะทุกวันมีอาหารแล้วแต่
วันนี้ยังไม่มีอาหารเลยใช่ค่ะอุแต่ก็ดีนะ
เพราะว่าอย่างครูเรียมไม่มีลูกใช่มยยัง
ไม่ได้แต่งงานไม่มีลูกครูเรียมตื่น 88:30
นมีเวลาครึ่งชั่วโมงก็อาบน้ำแปรงฟันแล้ว
ก็มาอัดวิดีโอได้หูแต่ถ้ามีลูกเนี่ยตื่น
8:00 น
นี่ไม่ได้นะคะ
ใช่น่าจะต้องตืถ้าวันอังคารถ้าเกิดแบบลูก
โตนิดนึงแล้วลูกต้องไปโรงเรียน
โอ้โหตอนเช้านี่น่าจะป่วนน่าดูเลยอ่ะอื
วุ่นวายวุ่น
วายใช่ครูเรียมก็ต้องทำอาหารแล้วก็บอกลูก
ตื่นอาบน้ำหรือยังเอาใส่เสื้อผ้าหรือยัง
อ่ะเดี๋ยวจะขึ้นรถนะครูเรียมก็ต้องทำ
อาหารมือก็ทำอาหารตาก็ดูลูกลูกมืออันนี้
ก็อาจจะจับลูกอยู่ป่วดมากๆเลยนะคะตอนเช้า
ๆเออลูกก็แบบจะมาป่วนไงก็แบางทีแบบทำกับ
ข้าวอยู่ใช่มั้ยก็จะแบบมาจับมาจับแบบเตา
อ่ะที่มันร้อนๆน่ะที่แบบจับแล้วแบบอ๊ร้อน
ๆเราก็คนเป็นแม่นะก็ไม่อยากให้จับเราก็
แบบรู้สึกว่าลูกเป็นตัวป่วนใช่นะยิ่งแบบ
เด็กเล็กๆเนาะเวลาแบบอย่างคุณหญิงเคยไป
ร้านอาหารอ่ะค่ะแบบร้านอาหารร้านอาหาร
ญี่ปุ่นมั้งจำไม่ได้แล้วอ่ะน่าจะเป็นร้าน
อาหารญี่ปุ่นเพราะว่าเด็กๆจะเยอะใช่มย
เด็กๆเนี่ยเด็กๆจะชอบกินอาหารญี่ปุ่นมัน
จะไม่เผ็ดอืเด็กจะกินได้อ่ะค่ะแล้วแบบ
เด็กก็คือ
วิ่งทั้งร้านเลยอ่ะแบบหรือบางทีก็ปีนแล้ว
ก็แบบพี่กินอะไรอย่างเงี้ยแบบป่วนมากๆอ่ะ
ใช่แล้วเรียมก็เลยแบบไม่ค่อยชอบเด็กถ้า
เกิดแบบเด็กเป็นแบบเนี้ยเรียมก็แบบ
อผู้หญิงก็บคุณแม่คุณแม่เขาก็กินนะเคก็
ไม่ดูลูกเลยอ่ะู้หญิงก็แบบเฮ้ยทำไมแม่ให้
ลูกวิ่งป่วนโต๊ะอื่นๆในร้านอาหารน่ะใช่
ใช่ก็คือแบบวิ่งมาแล้วทำให้คนอื่นแบบรู้
สึกว่ามันวุ่นวายอ่ะอือกินข้าวไม่ได้ใช่อ
แบบอย่างเช่นเรานั่งกินข้าวในร้านอาหาร
ใช่มยแล้วเด็กแบบเดินมาแล้วก็แบบมาจับดึง
เสื้อเราแบบเนี้ยอือแล้วก็ไข่อเราก็คิดอ
ไข่มาอืทำไมทำไมแม่ไม่ดูลูกเลยให้ลูกป่วน
โต๊ะอื่นๆอยู่ได้อเออครูเรียมเคยเจอ
เหมือนกันใช่มยคะแบบเด็กที่แบบวิ่งแล้วก็
ไปป่วนคนอื่นในร้านอาหารเคยค่ะเคยอืถ้า
เกิดแบบนิดหน่อยอ่ะแล้วแบบมันก็น่ารักมัน
ก็เอโอโอเคอยู่แต่ถ้าเกิดแบบคเสียงดังแบบ
กรี๊ดรี๊ด
ีดแล้วก็แบบแบบโยนช้อนโยนซ่อม
อือันนั้นแบบเรียมแบบเห็นแบบเป็นตัวป่วน
เลยตัวป่วน
เลย
อันนั้นไม่ไหวนะคะพ่อแม่ต้องดูแลด้วยไม่
ไหไม่ได้คือต้องออทำอะไรสักอย่างใต้องบอก
อืใช่เหมือนผู้หญิงเคยดูวิดีโอนึงอ่ะแต่
ไม่ใช่ในประเทศไทยนะเหมือนเห็นใน Facebook
บ้างคะน่าจะแล้วมันจะมีเด็กมันเป็นร้าน
อาหารที่เป็นเอ่อเหมือนบุฟเฟ่ต์น่าจะชาบู
อ่ะค่ะแล้วก็เราเนี่ยเดินมามันก็จะมีตู้
ตู้เนี่ยมันก็จะมีหมูมีไก่มีผักสมมุติครู
เรียมอยากกินอะไรเนาะครูเรียมก็เดินมา
แล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็หยิบก็จะมีใส่จานมีหมูมี
ไก่มีเนื้ออยู่ในตู้อ่ะค่ะเหมือนตู้เย็น
น่ะค่ะครูเรียมก็มาเดินแล้วก็หยิบใน
วีีดีโออ่ะก็เหมือนกับมีเด็ก 1 คนน่ะค่ะ
ไม่ไม่รู้ว่าคุณแม่นั่งอยู่โต๊ะไหนเขาก็
วิ่งแล้วก็วิ่งวิ่งไปป่วนทุกโต๊ะเลยเลย
อ่ะแบบไม่รู้จักอ่ะแบบครูเรียมกำลังนั่ง
กินอยู่เก็จะวิ่งมาป่วนหยิบจานแล้วก็วิ่ง
ไปป่วนโต๊ะนี้วิ่งไปป่วนโต๊ะนี้แล้วก็
วิ่งมาแล้วก็เปิด
ตู้ตู้ที่เป็นตู้อาหารน่ะค่ะแล้วเนี่ยคือ
แล้วพอมันเปิดอ่ะมันก็เปิดแรงเนาะเด็กอ่ะ
ค่ะเหมือนเค้าตัวเล็กอ่ะแล้วตู้มันอาจจะ
หนักมันแบบตู้เย็นน่ะเก็เปิดแรงแล้วตู้
มันก็ล้ม
ทับแต่ว่า
คือเราดูวีดีโอเราก็รู้สึกแบบอืก็สมควรนะ
เพราะว่าคนป่วนเหลือเกินสมมากใช่คใช่แต่
แต่เด็กก็ไม่เป็นไรนะคะพอดีพนักงานที่
ร้านน่ะเขมาแล้วเขาก็ดันดันตู้ไว้ให้เออ
แล้วเด็กก็ลุกขึ้นแล้วก็วิ่งไปป่วนโต๊ะ
อื่นต่ออ
ออทำไมพ่อแม่ไม่ดูใช่มยใช่ค่ะแบบป่วนมากๆ
เลยอ่ะแบบอืโอโห
แต่ว่าถ้าเกิดพูดถึงเรื่องป่วนอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยมันไม่ใช่แค่เด็กอย่างเดียวนะที่แบบ
เป็นเป็นตัวป่วนได้อ่ะเป็นตัวป่วนที่ไป
ป่วนคนอื่นอออย่างเด็กที่คุหญิงเล่าเมื่อ
กี้เนี่ยก็คือตัวป่วนแล้วก็ไปป่วนทุกโต๊ะ
เลยที่เคกำลังกินข้าวอยู่ใช่แล้วมันมี
อะไรที่แบบเป็นตัวป่วนได้อีกอ่ะค่ะหรือ
ว่าไปป่วนคนอื่นได้สุนัขอ่ะหมาของเราหรือ
ว่าสัตว์เลี้ยงบางอย่างครูหญิงเคยเห็นใน
คลิปวีดีโอมยเวลาที่มีคนออกกำลังกายอ่ะ
เขาจะมีเสือโยคะใช่มยปูเสือโยคะแล้วก็ออก
กำลังกายออกกำลังกายแล้วก็จะมีหมามาเดิน
แล้วก็
แบบเออๆเพราะว่าบางครั้งเราออกกำลังกาย
เราจะต้องยกขาเอ่อยกแขนใช่มั้ยยกขาอะไ
อย่างเงี้ยหรือว่าอาจจะกระโดดใช่มั้ย
กระโดดตกเออแล้วหมามันมาป่วนแล้วเออก
กำลังกายได้เหรอคะก็ไม่ได้ต้องแบบต้องหลบ
ต้องหลบหมาหลบหมาแล้วก็
อืหมาน่ะเป็นตัวป่วนอืออกกำลังกายอยู่ก็
แบบมาเดินๆๆๆแล้วก็เบียดไปแล้วก็เบียดมา
ถูๆถไปอ้าอืหมาที่บ้านเป็นนะทำแบครูเรียม
ถ้าเวลาูครูเรียมออกกำลังกายหมาที่บ้าน
ครูเรียมเนี่ยมาป่วนมยคะมาป่วนค่ะอเค้าก็
จะแบบมานอนบนเสือ
โยคะที่ที่เราแบบต้องแบบออกกำลังกายแล้ว
ก็มา
นอนก็แบบเอ๊แล้วูเรียมทำยังไงอ่ะทำยังไง
ดีเรียมก็แบบเวลาจะเอามือลงใช่มั้ยเรียม
ก็แบบขยับไปที่อื่นก็แบบอ่ะเอาลงตรงนี้
แล้วกันเอามือวางตรงนี้ไม่ได้ก็ต้องแบบ
อ่ะวางตรงนี้แล้วกัน
อืๆใช่ถ้าเกิดแบบอยู่คนเดียวไม่มีหมาก็จะ
แบบสบายๆแต่อันนี้ยก็มีหมาไม่มีใครมาปวด
ใช่มีหมามาป่วนอ
อืจริงๆหรือว่าถ้าแบบเป็นผู้ใหญ่แบบเรา
อย่างเงี้ยแบบผู้หญิงครูเรียมก็คือโตแล้ว
ใช่มั้ยคะเป็นผู้ใหญ่แล้วเราก็เป็นตัว
ป่วนได้มั้ยเราก็ไปป่วนคนอื่นได้มั้ยได้
นะได้อืมครูเรมเคยเไปป่วนใครมั้ย
คะหรือเคยมีใครมาป่วนครูเรียมมั้ยมีอ่ะ
เรียมคิดว่าเรียมเคยอ่ะเคยไปป่วนคนอื่น
เวลาแบบบางคนเทำงานเทำงานกันซีเรียสมาก
เลยเรียมก็แบบเวลาเรียมเห็นเรียมก็ทำไม
ทำไมถึงซีเรียสทำไมถึงเครียดขนาดนั้น
เรียมก็จะแบบเข้าไปแล้วก็แบบแกล้งแกล้ง
อะไรสักอย่างเหมือนบางทีแบบอยู่กับเพื่อน
อย่างเงี้ยเวางโทรศัพท์ไว้ใช่มยเลมก็จะ
แบบ
ค่ะซ่อนไว้แล้วเพื่อนก็ทำงานทำงานทำงานทำ
งานสสักพักนึงเพื่อนก็เลยแบบเห็นโทรศัพท์
มยเพื่อนจะต้องใช้โทรศัพท์ทำงานใช่มยป่วน
ไปป่วนเค้าเป่วนแล้วก็แบบทำอะไรไม่
เห็นอยู่ไหนเอาโทรศัพท์ไว้ไหนไม่รู้ผู้
หญิงเคยเห็นคนทำแบบแบบนี้มยแบบเอาของคนไป
ซ่อนน่ะเคเคยเคยเออผู้หญิงเคยทำมั้ยผู้
หญิงก็เคยทำค่ะแบบอยากแกล้งอ่ะเหมือนมัน
ก็ป่วนนิดๆหน่อยๆอ่ะเนาะมันไม่ได้ป่วน
อะไรเยอะขนาดนั้นแต่แบบว่าอยากแกล้งแบบ
อาจจะไม่ใช่โทรศัพท์ผู้หญิงก็จำไม่ได้นะ
ว่ามันคืออะไรแต่มันเป็นของที่เขาต้องใช้
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะแต่แบบเาต้องใช้ทำเแบบเหือน
เขาจะต้องใช้แล้วอ่ะอีก 5 นาทีอย่างเงี้ย
เราก็แบบเห็นมันวางอยู่แล้วก็หยิบไปแล้ว
ก็แบบไม่
รู้ไม่เห็นไม่ใช่ของเราของคุณใครจะรู้เออ
แล้วเก็แบบเราก็จะเห็นเพื่อนเราแบบออยู่
ที่ไหนเนี่ยถ้าไม่มีทำงานไม่ได้แน่ๆเลย
เราก็แบบเราก็จะรู้สึกเออทำไมเราเป็นคน
แบบนั้นมันสนุกไงแต่ถ้าเ้ามาป่วนเรา
เพื่อนมาป่วนเราเคมาป่วนเราบ้างเราก็จะ
แบบไม่สนุกเออไม่สนุกใช่มยแต่ถ้าเราไป
ป่วนคนอื่นสนุกนะคะสนุกใช่อือูแต่ว่ามัน
มีป่วนบางอย่างที่อันตรายกว่านี้นะผู้
หญิงหืป่วนอะไรคะครูเรียมป่วนแบบอย่าง
เช่นแบบมีงานคอนเสิร์ตอย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็มี
คนมาแบบยิงปืนน่ะปั้งๆๆอย่างเงี้ยอก็เข้า
มาป่วนิคอนเสิร์ตเหมเหมือนคนกำลังสนุกใช่
มั้ยแบบโอ้ดูนักร้องแล้วก็กำลังเต้นอยู่
ในคอนเสิร์ตอแล้วอยู่ดีก็มายิงปืนให้คนตก
ใจแล้วก็วิ่งคนตกใจแล้วก็วิ่งออือเค้ามี
ความสุขของเแต่ทุกคนเนี่ยวิ่งๆๆๆๆๆแบบอัน
นี้ถือว่าแบบร้ายแรงนะแบบไม่ดีอไม่ดีมาก
แต่ที่เราเอาโทรศัพท์เไปซ่อนเมื่อกี้ก็
แบบก็ไม่ดีนะก็ไม่ดีแต่ว่าน้อยหน่อยเอออ
เฮ้ยพอครูเรียมพูดอันเนี้ยครูหญิงก็คิด
ขึ้นได้ว่าแบบมันก็จะมีคนคนที่อันนี้ก็
ไม่รู้ว่าเรียกว่าปวดหรือเปล่านะคะมันก็
จะมีคนที่แบบว่าบางทีอย่างในออฟฟิศในตึก
หรือว่าจะเป็นบริษัทเกำลังมีงานกินข้าว
กันอยู่ที่บ้านหรือที่ไหนสักที่นึงอ่ะค่ะ
แล้วมันก็จะมีคนที่วิ่งเข้ามาแล้วก็บอกไฟ
เมยอย่างเงี้ยจะไฟไหม้เนาะทุกคนก็ตกใจแบ
กินข้าววิ่งเหยียบกันอย่างเงี้ยอันนี้ก็
ถือว่าป่วนมั้ยป่วนอืมาป่วนงานททำให้แบบ
เค้ากำลังทำงานอยู่ดีๆแล้วทำให้เกิดบาง
อย่างขึ้นที่ทุกคนต้องตกใจหรือว่ารู้สึก
ไม่ดีแล้วก็วิ่งกันแบบเอออนี้ก็ปอันนี้
ไม่ดีนะคะไม่ดีเลยเหมือนแบบบางครั้งเราก็
จะได้ยินคนที่ชอบป่วนบนเครื่องบินอย่าง
เงี้ยเพราะว่าเวลาเราขึ้นเครื่องบินน่ะ
ค่ะเาจะไม่ให้เราพูดคำว่าระเบิดใช่มยอืม
บุมอ่ะระเบิดอ่ะเออใช่มั้ยถ้าแบบบางคนน่ะ
แบบนึกสนุกขึ้นมาค่ะแบบอยากจะป่วนสายการ
บินอย่างเงี้ยก็พูดขึ้นมาว่าแบบระเบิด
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะโหแอร์โฮสเตจกัปตันเนี่ยคือ
เครื่องก็จะเอาขึ้นไม่ได้เลยหรือว่า
เครื่องกำลังบินอยู่ถ้ามีคนพูดคำว่า
ระเบิดขึ้นมาคือไม่มีหรอกนะแต่แบบอยาก
ป่วนน่ะเรว่าแบบเคยได้ยินเครื่องบินก็
ต้องลงเลยนะใช่มั้เคยได้ยินว่าแบบมีคนพูด
แบบนี้แหละว่าแบบมีระเบิดในเครื่องบินมี
ระเบิดอืแล้วเค้าอ่ะก็เลยแบบไม่ให้ไม่ให้
บินขึ้นบนฟ้าก็เลยต้องหยุดทุกอย่างแล้วก็
ตรวจว่ามีระเบิดจริงหรือเปล่ากี่ชั่วโมง
อ่ะใช่คิดดูเครื่องต้องดีเลย์กี่ชั่วโมง
ใช่ค่ะแล้วแบบยิ่งถ้าเครื่องบินกำลังบิน
อยู่อ่ะอ่ากัปตันน่ะค่ะคนขับเครื่องบินก็
ต้องเอาเครื่องลงจอดแล้วก็ตรวจทั้ง
เครื่องอย่างเงี้ยอันนี้คือแบบป่วนมากเลย
นะแล้วคนอื่นที่นั่งบนเครื่องบินด้วย
เดือดร้อนน่ะอันนี้ไม่ดีนะคะไม่ดีเราเอา
โทรศัพท์ไปซ่อนไม่ยังไม่ดีน้อยกว่า
นะใช่ความผิดของตัวเองเนี่ยน้อยๆ
น้อยใช่ความผิดของคนอื่นจะเยอะเออใช่หรือ
ว่าแบบว่าบางทุกคนก็ไปเป็นตัวป่วนนั่น
แหละตั้งแต่เด็กๆมาใช่มั้ยป่วนพ่อกับแม่
โตขึ้นมาก็ป่วนเพื่อนใชอืโตขึ้นมาอีกก็
ป่วนที่ทำงานหรือว่าแบเออหรือว่าแบบเห็น
คนกำลังทำอะไรแล้วก็เข้าวิ่งเข้าไปอืทำ
ให้เขาตกใจอย่างเงี้ยก็ไปป่วนเค้าเออใช
อุยุหญิงเียมเคยดูในหนังนะที่แบบผู้ชาย
กับผู้หญิงแบบกำลังนั่งอยู่ในสวนสาธ
สธารณะนั่งแบบปิกนิกในสวนสาธารณะกัน 2 คน
แล้วก็มีตัวป่วนเข้าไปตัวป่วนทำอะไรคะ
เหมือนแบบเอาอะไรเอาสัตว์อะไรแบบไปโยนใส่
อ่ะเหมือนเอางูงูปลอมอ่ะไปโยน
ใส่อืให้เค้าตกใจเล่นตกใตกใจออยอันนี้
อันตรายมากๆนะบางคนแบบกลัวมากๆนี่อาจจะ
แบบไม่สบายได้เลยนะแบบตกใจมากๆอ่ะใช่เ
กำลังโรแมนติกกันอยู่อแล้วแบบไปป่วนคน
อื่นไงโยนงูเข้าไปออืหรือว่าใช่แต่ถ้าเรา
เป็นเด็กเนาะบางครั้งเราก็ปวดในคลาสใน
คลาสเรียนอย่างเงี้ยมีมั้ยแบบคุณครูกำลัง
สอนอยู่ผู้หญิงทำอะไรบ้างในคลาสเรียนผู้
หญิงไม่เคยทำหรอกนะเออเพราะ
ว่าแต่แบบบางทีแบบดูหนังไงแบบมันก็จะแบบ
เหมือนเด็กอ่ะออดาใช่่มแล้วก็พับแล้วก็ปา
ปาปาเครื่องบินปาใส่ครูอย่างเงี้ยเออทำ
ให้ครูแบบสอนไม่ได้ก็เหมือนป่วนมป่วนใน
คลาสเรียนในห้องเรียนป่ห้องเรียนใช่หรือ
บางทีก็ขยำกระดาษแล้วก็ปาไปแบบปาไปใส่
เพื่อนที่เรียนในห้องเดียวกันนั่นแหละใช่
ค่ะก็กวนเพื่อนอีกอ่ะเพื่อนกำลังตั้งใจ
ฟังครูสอนอยู่
ใช่อือื
ใช่ตัวป่วนเยอะนะเราใช่ๆค่ะโอตัวป่วนเยอะ
ค่ะคือผู้หญิงกำลังคิดว่าเอ๊ะบางครั้งผู้
หญิง
ก็คือเหมือนกับอันนี้ก็ไม่รู้ว่ามันมัน
ป่วนหรือเปล่าคือคอนโดมิเนียมผู้หญิงอาจะ
มีนกเยอะมากๆอ่ะคะอืมันจะมีนกเยอะมากๆอ่ะ
เออแบบบางครั้งมันก็ชอบบินมาแบบเรากำลัง
คือมันจะเราจะทำอาหารอยู่ข้างนอกไงข้าง
นอกไม่ได้ทำอาหารข้างในคอนโดเพราะว่าใน
ห้องเนี่ยไม่มีไม่มีที่ดูดควันน่ะค่ะฮู้ด
อ่ะเวลาเราทำอาหารใช่มยมันจะเปิดฮู้ดแล้ว
มันจะดูดควันน่ะคอนโดมิเนียมผู้หญิงเนี่ย
ไม่มีใช่ไหมถ้าแบบผู้หญิงทำอาหารแล้วมัน
มีควันเยอะๆอ่ะพวกเซ็นเซอร์สำหรับไฟไหม้
อ่ะค่ะมันจะเป็นสีแดงอออ่าผู้หญิงก็จะเออ
มันจะแบบมันจะจับสัญญาณดีมากๆอ่ะรปพเนาะ
ยามอ่ะค่ะปี๊ดๆเนี่ยเขาจะขึ้นมาออก็แบบ
อาหารไม่ทำอาหารในห้องใช่มั้ยเมนึกว่าจะ
มีน้ำฉีดลงมายังค่ะยังแต่มันแบบปี๊ดๆๆเขา
ต้องขึ้นมาปิดอ่ะเออต้องขึ้นเข้ามาในห้อง
เราอ่ะแค่ผัดกะเพราเองนะคะผัดกะเพราแล้ว
มีควันอ่ะไอ้พวกไอ้เซ็นเซอร์ไฟไหม้อ่ะค่ะ
มันก็จะเป็นสีแดงๆติ๊ดๆๆๆแล้วอ่ะเออผู้
หญิงก็จะทำกับอาหารน่ะอยู่ข้างนอกแล้วมัน
ก็จะชอบมีนกอ่ะนกพิราบอ่ะประเทศไทยมีนก
พิราบเยอะนะคะอีนกอเมริกาก็มีเออนั่นแหละ
นกพิร่ามันจะชอบบินมาแล้วเราก็
แบบอีน้องพิล่ามันมีแบคทีเรียใช่มยมัน
สกปรกอ่ะเราก็รู้สึกแบบเอ้ยอาไปแล้วแล้ว
มันก็ไม่กลัวนะูเรียมคือมันบินมาป่วดเรา
แล้วเราบอกไปมันไม่ไปนะบางทีตีอย่างเงี้ย
ตีเหรอไม่ได้ตีนกนะตีกระจกคือมันจะมี
กระจกเออให้มันดังใช่มั้ยนกอยู่แล้วก็ตี
มันก็ไม่ไปนะครูเรียมมันไม่กลัวอ่ะเรียม
นึกว่าแบบครูหญิงแบบตีนกได้เลยปไม่เอาค่ะ
ถ้าตีแล้วมันบินมาเกาะหัวเราขึ้นมานี่อ๋อ
เอไม่ไหวอ่ะเออคือเา้าจะมาตอนที่ครูหญิง
ทำอาหารคือเค้ามาบ่อยๆอยู่แล้วค่ะครู
เรียมเชอบบินมามันมันเยอะอ่ะมันเยอะมากๆ
เลยอ่ะเออแต่บางทีถ้าเราอยู่ข้างในห้องอื
ก็ไม่เป็นไรใช่มยมันไม่ได้มาป่วนอะไรเรา
เอออยากคุณอยากบินอยู่ตรงนั้นก็บินแต่ถ้า
เราออกไปข้างนอกแล้วเราทำอาหารเราก็แบบ
ไม่อยากให้นกมาไงเพราะว่านกเวลามันบินอ
มันจะมีแบบขนของมันหลุดอย่างเงี้ยร่วงลง
มาเราแบบเราก็ไม่อยากให้มันมาป่วนเราใช่
มยในตอนที่เรากำลังทำอาหารอยู่ไงใช่ครู
หญิงครูหญิงไม่คิดบ้างหรอว่านกน่ะคิดว่า
ครูหญิงออกมาทำไมออกมาป่วนนกทำไมไม่ใช่สิ
นกต้องมาป่วนครูหญิงอันนี้ห้องครูหญิงนก
ไม่รู้นกรู้แค่ว่ามาที่นี่บ่อยๆแล้วทุกๆ
อย่างก็เรียบร้อยดีก็แบบเออสบายแต่วันนี้
ครูหญิงมาทำอาหารอะไรอ่ะเอออันนี้เป็นที่
ของนกใช่มั้ยอนี้เป็นที่ของนกใช่มั้ยอื
ผู้หญิงก็ต้องเอานกมันน่ะมาทำอาหารแล้ว
ล่ะค่ะเออใครป่วนใครมันจะได้ตายให้หดมัน
จะได้ไม่ต้องมาป่วน
เราอืน้องกอืเรื่องป่วนๆนี่ก็เยอะเหมือน
กันนะเนี่ยใช่ค่ะถ้าแบบปกติแล้วถ้าเราโต
แล้วเราก็ไม่ค่อยป่วนเท่าไหร่หรอกเพราะ
ว่ามันมันแบบโตแล้วเนาะเราก็จะไม่ทำนะคะ
แต่ว่าเวลาที่เราเป็นเด็กเราก็อาจจะเป็น
ตัวป่วนบ้างเนาะนิดหน่อยนะคะก็ไม่รู้ว่า
นักเรียนเคยป่วนอะไรมยอาจจะป่วนใน
โซเชียลมีเดียก็ได้นะูหญิงอาจจะไป
คอมเมนต์มี Facebook หลาย acc เงี้ยไป
คอมเมนต์แบบคุเรียมไม่เห็นสวยเลยสมมติคุ
เรียมคุเรียมซีเรียสใช่มยเรื่องอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยแบบชุดิเออใส่ชุดนี้แล้วไม่สวยเลยก็
ไปคอมเมนต์ป่วนครูเรียมเออแล้วเรียมก็จะ
ไปหาว่าใครเนี่ยใครใมาคอมเมนแบบนี้ใช่
แล้วก็มีอีก acc นึงแล้วก็มาคอมเมนต์อีก
ใช่ไม่สวยหรอกนี่ไคอมเมนต์ป่วนโซเชียลก็
มีนะเอมีเยอะมากใช่ค่ะเนาะแต่ว่าไม่รู้นะ
คะนักเรียนเคยป่วนใครยก็คอมเมนต์บอกเรา
ได้เนาะแต่ว่าวดีโอนี้หดเวลาแล้วใช่มั้ย
ใช่นักเรียนก็น่าเข้าใจน่าจะเข้าใจคำว่า
ป่วนแล้วแหละอืใช่ค่ะแล้วเวลาก็หมดแล้ว
ด้วยใช่ค่ะแล้วเดี๋ยวเรามาป่วนนักเรียน
ใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะคะใช่แล้วค่ะแต่วันนี้
ต้องลาไปก่อนแล้วค่ะครูหญิงค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ
ครูเรียมสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะน้อง
เร